it's great to welcome back to the
program today Allan Lichtman who is a
political historian and professor at
American University in Washington DC
he is also author of the book the case
for impeachment professor Lichtman great
to have you back to them my great
pleasure so I mean let's just jump right
into it at the end of 2018 you were
quoted as saying you believe Donald
Trump will be impeached during 2019
you've been talking about the case for
impeachment for a couple of years now
since your book came out do you still
believe this is going to happen I do
believe it's going to happen but the
Democrats have to get a little bit of a
backbone look I love Jerry Nadler the
head of the House Judiciary Committee he
was my high school debate partner back
in the 1960s but I hate the way he is
equivocating backing and filling putting
his finger in the political winds the
same with Nancy Pelosi the house leader
look Natalie said we're in a
constitutional crisis I agree but there
is a constitutional remedy and that is
impeachment the US House has the sole
authority for impeachment and the
founders advisedly put impeachment into
the Constitution not as some catastrophe
but as a legal peaceful and orderly
means for dealing with a rogue leader as
opposed to the way they dealt with them
in their own time assassination or
revolution and there are so many grounds
on which to begin an impeachment
investigation of course obstruction of
justice which was articles voted against
Richard Nixon and the Judiciary
Committee against Bill Clinton by the
full house of course abuse of power
failure to honor legal subpoenas
violation of the emoluments Clause of
the Constitution and probably financial
crimes including in
his charity to promote his election and
perhaps corrupting the inaugural
committee and of course we still don't
know whether or not he's compromised by
the Russians that should be more than
enough to begin an impeachment
investigation you don't wait until you
have all the evidence like they seem to
be saying an impeachment investigation
is designed to bring out the evidence
and you're much more likely to get your
subpoenas honored when they are directly
related to the sole constitutional
function of the house okay so let's
split this into three steps just so you
I and the audience are all clear about
which one you are predicting will be
reached if we imagine it in the
following way step one is the house
formally starts debate and investigation
of potential impeachment articles number
two would be the house actually files
those impeachment articles and number
three would be the Senate actually votes
to convict on impeachment and remove the
president which exactly is that you're
predicting we're going to see by the way
you've missed maybe the most important
step once a house votes an article or
more of impeachment
yes Senate does not vote rather a trial
is held yes yes the Senate automatically
presided over not by Mitch McConnell the
leader of the Senate but by Chief
Justice John Roberts this is critical
because this is formal and focused and
in a trial the house prosecutors smart
people like Jerry Nadler and Adam Schiff
get to point an accusing finger at the
president to present their case and his
lawyers have to defend him with credible
arguments and evidence not just spin and
the focus of the nation will be upon
this so of the four steps now that you
have very politely added one in between
the the second and third ones I outlined
which level of that four step process
are you actually predicting here I'm
predicting the impeachment and the trial
but as I said I have been bitterly
disappointed by the lack
a spine on the part of House Democrats I
don't know what they're afraid of
impeachment is the only way to hold this
president accountable and it's the only
way they're ever gonna get the evidence
they need to look into various
allegations of misdeeds look history
does not celebrate which of the
faint-hearted or Katherine the cautious
history celebrates those who are
courageous and bold enough to meet the
challenges of their time and if the
Democrats don't act they will become
worse enablers of Donald Trump than the
Republicans so let's go through all of
the devil's advocate arguments here one
is that it could go a different way for
Democrats that actually moving forward
on impeachment when we have every sense
that Republicans would never actually
vote to convict in the Senate could
potentially backfire on Democrats in
2020 and emboldened Donald Trump what
what do you say incorrect that's based
on a misreading of the impeachment of
Bill Clinton back in the late 1990s when
Democrats are now tearing their hair
look there was a backlash against the
impeachment of Bill Clinton and
Republicans lost some seats in the
midterm elections of 1998 yeah they lost
a few House seats they kept control of
the house but it gave them a vastly
bigger prize the presidency george w
bush won the presidency in 2000 by 537
votes in florida at a time when the vote
fowl goal was blunted by the cloud of
scandal and the Democrats best
campaigner by far Bill Clinton was kept
on the shelf
certainly Bill Clinton could have turned
more than 537 votes for Gore if he had
campaigned in Florida where over my keys
to the presidency which accurately
predicted against all the polls and the
pundits Trump's victory in 2016 has one
of the critical keys
the scandal key u-turn the scandal key
that diminishes the prospects of Trump
to be able to be really
that and nothing else has any
consequences and by the way yeah we have
no idea that the Senate might do after a
child one of the Lippmann rules of
politics is for incumbent office holders
their top priority may be your only
priority is survival they may not be
willing to go down with Donald Trump
when you talk about the the Clinton
circumstances and how they differ from
the circumstances today is that a part
of I mean I guess I don't know if you've
already analyzed the 20/20 reelection
campaign and whether the impeachment
question is one of the ones that your
prediction will hinge on or if you
believe that you are ready to make a
20/20 prediction outside of that I'm not
ready to make a 20/20 prediction but I
am willing to say absent turning the
scandal teeth through impeachment as of
this moment
Donald Trump is favored to be a look
reelected in 2020 in other words the
Democrats are going down the same rat
hole they went down in 2016
believing the pundits believing the
polls we're moving in the urn plus
Pelosi says Oh
the way to win is not by going after
Trump that's to go down the center line
with a sensuous candidate guess what if
that was the way the room Hillary
Clinton should have won in a landslide
she was the most sensuous candidate you
can get and the Democrats have nominated
lots of centrist candidates John Kerry
Al Gore might do caucus and guess what
they all had in common every one of them
lost so is that an advice that the
Democratic primary should be looking to
someone who is more progressive this
time around is a more progressive bit
more exciting my keys is charisma
someone who can merely excite the
electorate the way John F Kennedy did in
1960 or Barack Obama in 2000 and it's
rare it's a once a generation thing but
I hate to say this because I'm big on
the issues issues are totally irrelevant
no
has ever turned quote-unquote on the
issues when Ellen Reagan in 1984 one in
a huge landslide Monday when only his
home state of Minnesota if you took a
poll on the issues the Democrats were
ahead well so I think there's a
difference between let's see if we can
break that down a little bit I think
you're right that very often the
minutiae of issues is not super relevant
so like as an example Donald Trump by
those who voted for him was seen very
favorably generally untrained
most of the people who thought that
don't know the first thing about trade
they don't really understand NAFTA they
don't even really know what it is that
Donald Trump was proposing but they saw
him favorably in some kind of general
sense on the issue so might it be more
accurate to say that it's less about the
particulars of the policy you're
proposing than the perception that
you're going to take care of a
particular issue like that still does
seem to matter to me anymore David
you're very sure I don't understand
trade I'm not sure anyone understands
trade to be honest with you yeah
absolutely a part of being charismatic
is making people believe and I hope
genuinely that you're really going to
improve their lives
and beyond that that you inspire them to
something beyond the everyday humdrum of
their lives and the big picture on the
issues does matter people do not follow
the minutiae of the issues so maybe an
analogy would be if you believe
generally that Bernie Sanders for
example just to pick someone is going to
make healthcare more affordable and more
accessible whether it's expanding
Medicare or putting in a public option
or creating a system similar to the one
in the UK like that that level of
specificity is less relevant than the
perception that on that issue Bernie
Sanders is going to improve your life
absolutely but it's got to be delivered
with verve and style and people have to
believe it we need someone who's capable
of inspiration all of the centrist
experience non inspirational
kradic candidates and I've given you a
list of most of them every one of them
has lost who the Democrats have well
they are all Democrats Barack Obama
Jimmy Carter Bill Clinton candidates who
offered something new and different and
exciting and more than just another cog
in the establishment so to get back as
we we get sort of toward the ends of our
times the end of our time together it
sounds like you're saying if Democrats
don't impeach the most likely scenario
is Trump reelection I mean is it that
binary in your mind well nothing is
binary but that's where things stand now
obviously is a long time to go and
things can change here's the worst case
scenario the other Democrats they don't
impeach Donald Trump is reelected so
Donald Trump is empowered for another
four years to undermine our Constitution
or freedoms our liberty and our national
security and every future president is
empowered to do that and Democrats will
be reviled by history and instead they
have an opportunity to seize the moment
to be rich and the lion-hearted not rich
in the chicken-hearted yeah I mean I
that's why I'm having a hard time
getting away from the impeachment thing
because I can understand arguments that
it's possible like I know you disagree
it's possible that there could be
unforeseen strategic issues with him
with a failed impeachment attempt I
understand that we could make the
argument that hey maybe Mike Pence it
could actually get more damaging things
done for that's a debate that could be
had but I kind of go back to if not now
when like if this doesn't justify it
then what are we saying about the checks
and balances and infrastructure that the
founders established for the United
States we're sort of saying with
presidential immunity if we don't move
now we have taken two giant steps
towards autocracy in this country if
what this president has done does not
justify even an impeachment inquiry then
what possibly could we pretty much
empower our presidents to move ever so
much closer to
Putin in Russia which is exactly what
Donald Trump wants he wants to be an
autocrat and right now he feels he can
just walk over the spineless Democrats
and they're not going to do a damn thing
he couldn't care less about contempt of
Congress he couldn't care less about
going into the courts he loves it and in
fact you know if he gets an adverse
verdict in the court he'll just say it
was rigged and he'll follow the example
of his favorite President Andrew Jackson
who reportedly said after an adverse
Supreme Court decision Chief Justice
Marshall has made his decision now let
him enforce it only impeachment is the
proper appropriate constitutional check
on this president professor Allan
Lichtman 'he's book is the case for
impeachment he's a political historian
also a professor at American University
in Washington DC so appreciate your time
again on the program today
awesome David take care